the gentlewoman from New York MS Acacio
Cortez is recognized for five minutes
thank you so much madam chair I'm
grateful that we're having this hearing
today Thank You mr. Marquez for coming
42 testified before our committee so I
believe we're here today because
Facebook which is a publishing platform
an advertising network a personal
telecommunications network a
surveillance corporation a Content
distributor now also wants to establish
a currency and act through its wallet as
at minimum a payment processor and why
should these activities be consolidated
under one corporation Congresswoman the
the one thing that we are focused on
really is solving problems for the very
people who are left behind right now and
we believe it's important because we
have the ability to invest and we have
the product to deliver those services
that will solve problems the same way
we've reduced costs for people to
communicate on our messaging apps I see
Libra is according to your white paper a
unit of currency backed by a reserve
governed by the Libra Association now to
economist to members of Congress to
accountants the term backed has a very
specific meaning usually incorporates
monetary policy yet the Libra white
paper does not define backed rather it
states that Libra will be quote backed
by government currency and government
securities so what does back to mean in
this in your sense congresswoman
it means that it will have a reserve one
for one for every unit of Libra you will
have the corresponding value in stable
currency and so does this mean you know
as as stated the Libra Association is
not set monetary policy but it meant
sanborns coins in response to demand
from authorized resellers as it appears
today if there are more Canadian Libra
users than us users will there be more
median dollars in the leaper reserve to
meet potential redemptions no Congress
woman the way that the Reserve basket
will be determined will be stable and
continue to to be stable and we will we
will work with g7 working groups to
ensure that it has a thank you and so
this governance over the reserve is the
Libra Association correct yes it is
congressman
and so currently there Libra Association
is governed by Facebook uber eBay
Spotify Visa thrive Capital Union Square
Ventures and a handful of nonprofits as
well as some other partners correct it
is correct
were they democratically elected no
congresswoman but we hope that we will
have the proper regulatory oversight
because we agree with you that this
should have the proper oversight to
ensure proper who picked the founding
members of this governance over the
currency congresswoman the membership is
open based on certain criteria the first
27 other companies that have joined are
the companies that have shared that
desire to come and build this networking
soul Macy's so we are discussing a
currency controlled by an undemocratic
li.selected coalition of largely massive
corporations do you believe currency is
a public good congresswoman I believe
that sovereign currencies should remain
sovereign and we do not want to
challenge sovereign currencies we just
want to augment their capabilities in a
way that they can be but do you believe
currency is a public good congresswoman
I believe that sovereign currencies are
sovereign and as a result they should do
you believe secret should be a public
good
congresswoman again we will work with
all of the regulators and and address
all concerns and the regulator's will
don't I'll take that as a no I should
take that doesn't no it is not for me to
decide Congress okay I'll take that as a
no you stated yesterday in front of the
Senate committee that you would be
to accepting a hundred percent of your
pay in Libra in the history of this
country there is a term for being paid
in a corporate controlled currency do
you know what that term is
I do not kind of risk what's called
scrip are you familiar with scrip I am
not this way
um the idea that your pay could be
controlled by a corporation instead of a
sovereign government do you think that
there's any risk here you know we've
seen from script to the issues with how
Facebook handled our elections we're
seeing a destabilizing in our public
goods and by Phyllis's by facilitating
instantaneous purchases out to a digital
wallet calibra and Libra how how how
could my time is expired thank you very
much